so a texas man was arrested with
a rifle as well as 118
rounds of ammunition at kamala harris's
residence
the night before last a cnn reporter jim
schudo tweeting on wednesday night
around 9 00 pm eastern that quote
a texas man arrested outside vp kamala
harris's official residence at the u.s
naval observatory wednesday
was in possession of an ar-15
semi-automatic rifle
113 rounds of unregistered ammunition
and 5 30 round magazines
according to a washington dc
police report cnn
going on to say that the individual is
facing multiple charges
for the weapons as well as the
ammunition spokesperson for the d.c
police
said that officers went over about
quarter past noon on wednesday
because of a suspicious person based on
a bulletin
that actually originated from texas this
individual traveling
from texas detained by u.s secret
service
there had been a region-wide
intelligence bulletin
about this individual he is a 31 year
old man
from san antonio the rifle the
ammunition were recovered from his
vehicle
it's unclear at this time what his
intentions were
but many charges carrying a dangerous
weapon
carrying a rifle or shotgun outside of a
business possession of unregistered
ammunition possession of a large
capacity ammunition
feeding device and the individual
was um detained by
um i guess what you would call local
police
before secret service showed up we're
still learning more about what exactly
his motives were we don't yet know but i
think many of us can sort of
imagine and whenever this happens you
know this is i don't want to joke about
this
because what happened this is serious
and what happened in georgia
with the massage parlor shooting is also
serious
and insanely tragic with eight people
dead
but i started saying you know are we
going to hear this guy was also just
having a bad day
as per the day before yesterday's uh
press conference with jay baker the
spokesman for the cherokee county police
um was this guy just looking to improve
the country
as we heard from republican senator uh
ron johnson recently about
the january sixth uh uh rioters
will the gun people say oh the 118
rounds including the unregistered ones
those are just for hunting as many gun
rights people say
uh you should be allowed to have what is
the explanation going to be on this one
from different people
and of course good thing that this guy
was caught
but um certainly not uh
something that is boding particularly
well at this time you know think
when barack obama became president the
number of
death threats against the sitting
president when that stopped being george
w bush and started being barack obama
went
way up and um under
the trump presidency death threats
against the president again that rise to
the level where the secret service gets
involved and they're
considered serious went down and of
course there are people who are going to
say
that that this this is likely about race
there's no way to know that this
individual incident is
uh we we you know you can look at
broader data this particular incident we
don't know
um but my concern is
given all of the concerns over the last
two months since the january riots about
the role
of both military former and current
as well as law enforcement within the
rioters
i just want to make sure that the right
people are in the positions to be
preventing exactly this type of guy
from being able to uh do harm to
kamala harris or whoever it is that they
do want to do harm to
we will see as we learn more what the
explanation was why did he travel from
texas to dc
um with the with the rifle with the 118
rounds
at this point we just don't know i'm
really excited that
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
i sleep on a helix mattress at home i
absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them
about sponsoring the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video